Do you know anything about Dr. Mark Circus and his cancer, conquering cancer, hope you're
this?
Not really.
The only thing I know about him is he has done some things with sodium bicarbonate and
hydrogen medicine.
He's written some little booklets about that.
And I don't agree with all of the things that are out there like sodium bicarbonate therapy.
I would, we talked about that's at baking soda therapy.
So there's, there's a natural approach to cancer by taking baking soda orally.
Um, no, I'm not a fan of that because baking soda is extremely alkaline and you're going
to alkalize your stomach, which is going to, you know, which has a very strong potential
or if not for sure, that you're going to develop H. Pylori and, um, that's not good.
So will you be alkalizing your body by taking baking soda?
Well, I have a lot of this different blog posts and such but your body has buffering systems.
So it's, I don't know how much it is a urban myth anymore, but it, I used to have to combat
this urban cancer myth that cancer doesn't grow in an alkaline environment.
Cancer only grows in a acidic environment and there was this big urban myth and I don't
think it's as popular anymore, but it used to be really popular 20 years ago that, you
know, people getting pH strips and testing their urine and testing their saliva and oh my
gosh, it's too acidic, we need to get it more alkaline.
And then doing things to try to alkalize their body.
And I say this is a urban myth because it has nothing to do with, um, with real physiology.
So real physiology is that you have buffering systems in your body to, to keep things in balance
and if a person is too acidic or too alkaline, you can see that in their blood test.
You can't see that in your pH of your urine or can you see that in the pH of the saliva.
The pH of the urine just tells you the acidity or alkalinity of one's urine has nothing to
do with the acidity of alkalinity of your tissue, same thing with the saliva.
So that using pH strips to test your urine or test your saliva, I sure hope that nobody
listening to this is still doing that thinking that they're helping their body try to
alkalize their urine and or saliva thinking that they're alkalizing their tissues.
It's just not happening.
So if you took baking soda, no, if you had stomach cancer, um, and you did a baking soda
orally, there may be some benefit to that.
Um, but if you had, um, any other cancer, you know, there's really going to be absolutely
no benefit to that because you're, that's going to be buffered before it gets into the
blood.
You alkalize your blood.
You die.
If your blood varies very much to a 7.35 pH, which is fairly neutral, you would die.
So, um, that's, that's just not correct.
Now, would, would it be true to say that cancer itself, if you could go in there surgically,
not that person open, go in at the pH, pH, try to test the, the blue around the cancer,
would it be acidic?
Well, quite possibly because cancer is highly metabolic and it's spewing out a lot of waste,
like anything that is grove is going to have more waste.
Cell waste is dispersed outside of the cell membrane, right, into the extra cellular space
and that waste is typically going to be more acidic, that's going to be carried away.
So the person is toxic, meaning that they're not able to get rid of their waste, their
tissue is going to be more acidic.
And if you did a blood test on them, they may have what's called metabolic acidosis and that's
measured by looking at their sodium chloride levels, potassium levels in their blood.
So it doesn't mean their blood is acid, but it's, but when you have a variation of some metrics
in the blood, that's why you want to do a comprehensive metabolic panel.
It can show metabolic acidosis, but it can also show, you see metabolic alkylosis as
much as you see metabolic acidosis.
So how does a person get metabolic alkylosis or acidosis?
Well, it has to do with toxicity levels and ability to get rid of toxins.
And partly, it's not always like, oh, well, by liver's back, that could be your limb system
is backed up or, you know, so the toxins are getting out of the tissues, the toxins are toxins
maybe get into the blood, they're not getting out of the liver, remember, go back to the
seven phases of detoxification.
If any of those pathways are blocked, it could cause issues.
So that's what you want to look at.
So doing the sodium bicarbonate therapy, meaning taking sodium bicarbonate orally makes absolutely
no physiological sense now, well, could I inject sodium bicarbonate into a cancer?
Well, legally, now, there was a doctor, Simon Cheedy, who did that in Italy and he was in
prison for that.
Well, it wasn't a good thing.
We don't care what the authorities thought.
Well, we don't know, he had some indications that it did help with different breast cancers,
whether he injected sodium bicarbonate around the breast cancer, but you'd have to have
a pretty sophisticated clinic to do that because if you put a needle into a person's breast,
if you tried to inject sodium bicarbonate into the area and you punctured the tumor itself,
could you be spreading the cancer?
Yes.
And there's lots of dangers to things like that.
So some of the things aren't really feasible to do as a therapy, but that's another topic.
So no, I'm not completely familiar with this person.
I do know that he's talked about different therapies like iodide and things that I don't
know if he's just kind of selling brochures and books.
There's another guy who has written a lot of alternative books and they're usually shorter
books and he's an extremely good author and I read several of his books, but you have to
be careful that because I read a couple of his books that were nonsense, too, but he's
just taking data and trying to sell books.
So you have to be careful about that, too.
He's not actually a practitioner yet, doesn't actually see people.
So maybe this guy is a doctor, maybe sees people, he's seen, he has data from his patient
basin, how he's treating people.
So I don't discourage you from looking up other things, but I can't give really an opinion
about this person.